the first cases of coronavirus were
recorded here in the Chinese city of
Wuhan but the origin of the pandemic is
a sensitive topic for China Australia
sparked anger earlier this year
merely by calling for an inquiry it's
part of a trend of growing hostility
between Beijing and Western allies and
now this Australian organisations are
currently being targeted by a
sophisticated state-based cyber actor
this activity is targeting Australian
organisations across a range of sectors
including all levels of government
industry political organizations
education health essential service
providers and operators of other
critical infrastructure the Prime
Minister was careful to avoid public
attribution but his officials point
privately to China not true says Beijing
China is a staunch upholder of
cyberspace security and we have been a
victim of cyber attacks
we have been firmly opposing all forms
of cyber attacks our position has been
clear and consistent but Australia isn't
alone with its suspicions the UK last
month said laboratories working on
coronavirus vaccines were a threat in
cyberspace China backed hackers
allegedly among the suspects Australia's
High Commissioner told me this week
allies need to stick together
like-minded nations people who see the
world through similar eyes with similar
values like commitment to democracy and
liberal societies and and freedom
increasingly need to cooperate against
potential adversaries do you believe
that it's more important than ever for
Australia to build on that relationship
with the UK the benefit the importance
to each other of like-minded
free-trading liberal democracies like
Britain and Australia has never been
greater that said neither
country is looking for a fight with
China especially in the midst of a
pandemic where everyone is vulnerable
Deborah Haynes skinnies